advice for women dating in their early
20s don't sleep with people right
not unless that is a serious serious
relationship and
if you're
hooking up or dating someone and they're
like
yeah i don't really want to get married
just
dump them who cares about that person
like and if you think that you're going
to date them and then change them into
someone who does want to get married
they kind of sound like a loser to begin
with so get rid of that person that or
like sit them down and have a very
serious conversation and
ask questions like do you ever want to
get married okay well if you do when do
you want to get married and make sure
that your dreams align with their dreams
because if you're dating somebody and
they don't have any plan on getting
married then you're wasting your time
and
that's trickier for women because women
are
most attractive and most fertile when
they're young
and men i would say get more attractive
you know in their mid 30s maybe even 40s
and they get richer so
they have time that you don't have so
make sure the person that you're with
has the same kind of goals as you don't
just sleep around it doesn't help you
and don't be ashamed of actually talking
about what you want if you want to get
married and you want to have kids
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that and for some reason society at the
moment is telling young women that they
should just sleep around and work in
well into their 30s because having kids
forever is easy uh don't worry like
science has caught us up so you can have
kids whenever you want which
fortunately there are ways to have kids
and extend the period of time you can
have kids but some people aren't that
lucky and you don't know if you're one
of those people but
it's totally fine to talk to someone and
say hey i do want to get married i do
want to have kids that's healthy and any
sane man would be attracted to that
so
don't just
go with the flow which is at least when
i was in university which is
parties sleep around
and dampened down you know long-term
goals and i think it's also easier when
you get a bit older to differentiate
between who actually is smart and has it
together and who doesn't
i had a very difficult time when i was
in my early 20s figuring out who was
smart and who wasn't smart i think
that's my advice is for relationships
try to find somebody who aligns and
honestly if you're in university and you
can't find any guy who
doesn't suck
uh maybe go to church that might be a
way to do it people with christian
values are are pretty
solid people it's probably a
controversial thing to say
go fishing for a husband at church
but it might be a good idea ooh this is
fun when should the guy get married
before or after getting his career on
track i think it totally depends on who
you meet you don't want to meet the girl
of your dreams and then think well i
have to get my career on track and i
know there are a lot of red pill people
out there that are like just wait wait
till your mid-thirties get your career
on track make all your money then hook
up with a 23 year old because they're
most fertile at 23.
but if you find somebody you like i'm
not entirely sure who i was imitating
there if you find somebody you like then
just marry them because
marrying somebody and getting that
relationship
organized in your life
can
excel your career right if you have
someone there to help you that can
actually help your work life
and then
like role reversing i work with my
husband so it's a bit different but
being in a stable relationship with
somebody who's who helps me has made me
ten times more productive and i've made
him more productive so i think if you
find the right person it can help excel
your career so i wouldn't put off
marriage
um
but i would you know focusing on work as
a dude i think isn't a bad idea focusing
on work as a girl either i mean i like
working all the time all those people
online really that say
i i don't agree i don't agree with
people that put women in a category
that's like okay
you should be staying at home and having
kids and i know a lot of women who do
want to stay home and have kids
which is totally fine and if you do that
is healthy and you shouldn't be ashamed
of it but if you don't want to stay home
and have kids you also shouldn't be
ashamed of that i i know that if i
just stayed home and had kids i would go
bat [ __ ] so fast so fast
it'd be like six months and i'd be crazy
so i think and try and envision the life
that you want and make that happen
right and i wouldn't you know keep
your dreams small
i think you can dream up whatever you
want right and who says you can't have
that who like why is it that some people
become billionaires or start companies
and some people
have yachts some people achieve these
things or have
you know five kids some people achieve
these things so why couldn't that be you
right so
dream up however you want your life to
be and then
assume that that can happen and work
your way towards it right i think that
the glass ceilings that exist we just
put in place ourselves